Por aquí tenemos los datos de dos sitios web
distintos, el sitio web A y el sitio web B, y la
pregunta que te quiero hacer es ¿cuál de ellos es
más productivo? Algunos de ustedes se preguntarán
¿qué significa ser productivo? Bueno, en un nivel
muy alto, podemos ver la productividad como qué
tan eficaz es algo al producir, es decir, para una
cantidad dada de entrada en el proceso ¿qué tanto
obtenemos de salida? Si queremos ser un poco más
exactos podemos pensarlo como: la razón de salida
por entrada y esto nos hace preguntarnos ¿cuáles
son las salidas y cuáles son las entradas? Así
que pausa el video y piensa en cómo compararías la
productividad de estos dos sitios web, y, ojo, hay
muchas formas de hacerlo. Bueno, vamos a pensarlo
juntos, y lo primero que haremos será observar
cada uno de estos datos y pensar si son entradas o
salidas. Primero tenemos el número de escritores,
necesitamos escritores para producir el sitio web,
vamos a considerarlo como una entrada; aunque si
fueras el jefe de recursos humanos, la persona que
contrata escritores, entonces esto podría ser una
salida, pero si sólo estamos pensando en crear un
sitio web entonces necesitamos escritores para el
sitio y, por lo tanto, estos son una entrada.
Después tenemos el número de publicaciones, el
promedio del número de palabras por publicación,
el promedio de "Me gusta" por publicación,
el promedio de comentarios por publicación y el
número de suscriptores nuevos. Todo esto podemos
verlo como salidas, si los escritores hacen un
buen trabajo van a producir muchas publicaciones,
las cuales, supongo, tendrán muchas palabras
-aunque, no sé si eso sea siempre bueno-,
a las personas les gustarán sus publicaciones,
comentarán sus publicaciones y tendrán nuevos
suscriptores. Así que todo esto son salidas.
Bien, ahora ¿qué hay de los ingresos? Bueno,
esta es la cantidad de dinero que llega al
sitio antes de pagar sus gastos, por lo tanto,
también es una salida, ya que si los escritores
hacen un buen trabajo y el sitio se maneja bien,
generarán muchos ingresos. Y ¿qué hay de
los gastos? Bueno, necesitamos los gastos,
necesitamos gastar en cosas como: el salario de
los escritores para poder crear un sitio web para
generar así un ingreso, así que consideraremos
esto como una entrada. Y ¿qué hay de las
ganancias? Las ganancias son la diferencia entre
todo el dinero que llega menos los gastos. Bueno,
algunas personas pueden argumentar que la idea
principal de un negocio es generar ganancias;
este es el resultado que queremos maximizar, así
que vamos a considerarlas como salidas. Entonces,
la pregunta sobre la productividad sólo se
reduce a: ¿qué salida o qué combinaciones
de salidas queremos utilizar en la razón que
estamos generando en relación con alguna entrada
o alguna combinación de entradas? Una forma
realmente simple de calcular la productividad
en esta situación será definirla como las
ganancias entre el número de escritores, y una
vez más: hay muchas formas distintas de definirla.
Ahora bien, si la definimos de esta forma,
¿qué sitio web es más productivo? Bueno, dada esta
definición, el sitio web A tiene una productividad
de 10 mil dólares entre cinco escritores, entonces
tendremos 2 mil dólares de ganancia por escritor.
Y bajo esta definición, ¿cuál es la productividad
del sitio web B? Bueno, tenemos que dividir 28 mil
dólares entre 11: 28,000 / 11 nos da 2,545 si
lo redondeamos; entonces, aproximadamente 2,545
dólares de ganancia por escritor. Así que,
con base en esta medida de productividad,
parece que el sitio web B es más productivo.
Ahora, ¿qué pasaría si hacemos una más simple?,
o tal vez queremos pensar en una que sea un
poco más natural. Por ejemplo, pensemos en el
número de publicaciones por escritor, así
que hagámoslo de esta forma: si definimos
productividad de esta nueva forma como el número
de publicaciones entre el número de escritores,
entonces en esta situación el sitio web A
tiene una productividad de 110 / 5 que es 22,
22 publicaciones por escritor; y por su parte
el sitio web B tiene una productividad de 200
/ 11 -saquemos la calculadora-: 200 / 11 es 18.18,
pero lo redondearemos a 18 ya que queremos obtener
un aproximado, entonces, la productividad del
sitio web B es 18 publicaciones por escritor.
Bajo esta medición de productividad, el sitio
web A es más productivo. Espero que esto te dé
una idea general de qué es la productividad
y una apreciación de que existen distintas
formas de medirla. Incluso podemos hacer
cosas más sofisticadas, podemos hacer toda
una combinación de salidas y dividirla entre
toda una combinación de entradas. Por ejemplo,
podemos definir productividad como el número
de publicaciones por el promedio del número de
palabras por publicaciones, tomar esa cantidad,
y tal vez sumarla o multiplicarla al promedio
de "Me gusta" por publicación, y a eso sumarle
o multiplicarle el promedio de comentarios por
publicación, y después dividirlo por el número de
escritores o por el número de escritores y gastos,
o sólo dividirlo entre los gastos. Pero
la idea general es tomar una salida,
o alguna combinación de ellas, y dividirla
entre una combinación de entradas, y podemos
decidir cómo combinarlas, cómo queremos combinar
de manera matemática esas salidas y esas entradas.